[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote you decide and
we break it down every single friday in
the second hour of the tony michaels
podcast you can go vote on twitter at
tonymichaelspod
just go follow us over there you can
also
if you're on the tubes of you you can
subscribe to our youtube channel
and then you can vote on youtube as well
now it started it was this was the first
week we we did it we did it it worked
people were telling those requests i saw
it i saw it in the comments they said
hey not everyone's on twitter man it
happened i said all right i hear you i
feel you
i'll let you vote
here's our here's our contestants this
week we know uh uh butt mullet or butt
mohawk or representative madison gothorn
um well it's like a but like a hedgehog
you know yeah well an ass squatch
watch and ask watch
i come up with that name i think the
other day i said ass sasquatch but i
thought ah just complying yeah
and ask watch oh askwatch there maybe
that'll be my nickname for madison
gotham from now on you know some people
some people gabe call him settler i
think that's highly offensive so i will
not call him hitler
um i'm going to call him askwatch yeah
sasquatch that'll be that'll be good
oh my god ask watch
we also had uh susan collins and you've
seen their uh the united states federal
society supreme court justice
alito
for the decision i actually voted if you
look here um on my page let's see here
if i can bring this up i voted for susan
collins on the uh
wow
that's what i did and the reason why i
voted i voted for susan collins was
because i figured you know these ass
wipes she lied they lied to her um one
of the issues is why we have three trump
supreme court justices is because of
susan collins lies and her
her dumb [ __ ] right i i was like
gorsuch pointage promised me he wouldn't
kavanagh promised
whether she actually believed it or not
i don't know i think she's an idiot and
i think the state of maine deserves much
better than her as a senator we'll also
agree to only two terms
of service the other reason why she's on
the bone of the weak bull pole gabe is
because she said she will not support
right she said
it was too broad yeah it's too extreme
to give women their rights right oh my
god so between these three on uh you see
you see here the results on twitter
um for the twitter poll here um
you know
oh
susan susan collins susan collins let's
see if we can want some video maybe of
this bonehead let me see if i can find
some something yeah i'm sure you can
find all the receipts where she says
they can't be overturned it's precedent
they promised me
minus touch did a video i think it was
line gqp yeah i think and then what it
was called
yeah yeah i'll find out
yeah let me let me let me search that
one
that's a great breakdown tick tock tick
tock and then every time they like
see if we can find that um
video
well while you're doing that i hope
everyone out there is having a good
friday uh i hope you're all going to do
something fun this weekend or you know
just you know relax a little chill
netflix whatever
netflix and chill i mean you don't have
to do both you could just
chill and do netflix you have to netflix
and chill you know oh but i'm just
saying you know like you could go out
and you know you want to go for a hike
or go hang out at the park or whatever
go to the bar non-bone-headed type stuff
or just again hang out at your house and
just watch netflix that sounds great
so let's watch this video that minus
dutch did of line gqp and it features um
one of the contestants
which is
susan collins is watching i believe the
constitution protects the right to
privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
[Music]
roe versus wade is an important
precedent of the supreme court it was
decided in 1973 it has been challenged
on a number of occasions and the supreme
court has reaffirmed the decision when a
decision is challenged and it is
reaffirmed that strengthens its value
pro versus wade decided in 1973
suppressed the united states supreme
court
it has been reaffirmed so a good judge
will consider it as precedent of the
united states supreme court worthy as
treatment of president like any other
[Music]
as a judge it is an important precedent
of the supreme court by it i mean roe v
wade and planned parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
[Music]
i do not believe that brett kavanaugh
will overturn presidents are overturned
all the time
they aren't overturned all the time he
views precedent not just as a legal
doctrine but is rooted in our
constitution neil gorsuch for whom you
voted don't you think he's probably
going to vote to overturn roe vs wade if
given the chance i actually don't
row is not a super precedent because
calls for its overruling have never
ceased but that doesn't mean that rose
should be overruled
now obviously all these [ __ ] could be
on bonehead of the week this week
um and but but this video and the fact
that susan collins
were to uh
this seems like a lie to the american
people but to her constituents in maine
is probably the main reason why
i decided to vote for susan collins now
you know i don't know if that was the
correct decision but we'll we'll we'll
work through it um
now
our one of our other contestants here
madison catherine we know
oh my god we
do we do we know more about madison
gotham than we want to know um this week
was definitely revealing
uh
you know of
some
private stuff right and you know
the whole sketch no ask watch video yeah
no one here's the thing nobody asked for
that video uh but uh but it found its
way on the internet and um
you know
we said it yesterday you know
unfortunately we have to comment on it
because it is
unfortunately part of the political
sphere right now whatever that means
whatever that means yeah i don't know
you know what is politics in the year
2022 because it's an absolute [ __ ] show
if you watch this video um
it's hard to
play it on like youtube uncensored so
gabe made a censored version where it
has madison gawthorne's head um and the
best part about it gabe and i know i
don't i can't figure out if that video
is hilarious like the original one if
it's hilarious if it's gross like it's
it's all kinds of mixed females i mean
but the one you made the one you made at
the end where the head is like
the head is moving with the humping
that's the best it's hilarious it's
hilarious and speaking of that i got uh
and madison got there and uh paulie
teaks did a a video here and that's why
i'll preview that but he says um he says
breaking madison cawthorne oh i haven't
seen this one proposes a gqp
congresswoman susan uh dilemmas on the
steps of the people's house in new
hampshire so this is a uh state rep and
her name is susan dilemma she's a state
i notice she's a state senator or state
replied she and they state she's a state
uh uh representative right right right
in that state she's an elected official
and this is what she's doing deciding to
use her right she goes on the steps as
she's entering which hey she's got the
freedom to yell and scream back
but let's let's act like a professional
here well do you really think anyone in
the republican party i mean jesus christ
i'm asking you a miracle here i'm asking
for a miracle i know i understand that i
get it askwatch himself admitted that
they have the cocaine field orgies yeah
i
mean
you saw what happened to him he's right
exactly on the gop in there well
apparently in this fix that paulie teak
says here um because she's yelling at uh
pro-women
supporters at the capitol who are
pro-women who are who are there to fight
for women's rights and she's yelling and
screaming at them but let's see how
if
if paul
fixed the video here
um and i don't know what this has to do
with madison cawthorn but we'll find out
[Applause]
i can't even hardly look away um
if everyone's watching it appears that
madison cawthorne is um
maybe i don't know um
seems to be forcing himself on the back
of that woman's head i guess so i guess
so thank you for the fix ball
we really appreciate it here on uh on
bone end of the week um
really honestly that video
by paul right there it almost
encapsulated our whole week of politics
in that one crazy video there don't you
think yeah i mean
geez you know the day when you could
think back to like oh bush was dodging a
shoe
to
now these guys are
are getting videos released of them
humping and
assaulting and
now it's a dog with madison cawthorne's
face on it humping the back head of this
woman who's insanely screaming at pro
women
like what uh
it just gets the whole week in one
little video one little video so thank
you paul i am i'm i'm a fan of paul i'm
a vanna
uh here's another video um apparently
you what last week uh marjorie hopefully
green
was on excuse me marjorie trailer i see
marley marjorie no no we got
confirmation yesterday she has at least
four toes right but she's still a hoof
foot yeah yeah yeah yeah i can still
guard her but i can't call her three
toes right right
three toes right the three toes that
nickname
it's been debunked it has been debunked
we'll show you proof here in just a
second of that if we can do that on can
we do that on bone of the week bring in
someone who's not exactly just because
we bring it up the proof we can do that
i mean you mentioned her name okay well
we're allowed so here is a video
apparently um this is another reason why
madison gother and i don't know if he's
trending or not but you remember last
week we had uh uh acosta from cnn he he
was following marjorie taylor green hoof
foot and he was asking her
um about some things about tapes and
text messages and perjuring herself
on the stand at her hearing and she did
not like that and i believe that's why
she ended up on bone end of the week
last week or one of the reasons why
right right but he did the same thing
to madison cawthon apparently he had to
run a little faster i think though
because uh um
madison
uh can roll away as opposed to run away
so let's let's watch
let's watch what happens here in this
here's what happened
congressman you got a second just want
to ask you about the
any chance we get a quick comment here
at the crosswalk
what's that just contact our uh request
secondary football actually unrelated
question about
president trump saying that uh he wanted
to get dirt from putin you know what now
that i'm seeing this gabe
this this video is from uh from a while
ago but people are circulating this
around i wonder if if today if
if jim could ask him a question if he
would ask him what the hell is that in
your ass
yeah yeah one confirmed did you right
between the cheeks what what in the [ __ ]
is that what in the hell is that we've
seen a lot of things of what people
believe it to be some people say it's
hair some people say it's a toy some
people say it's
something else
right
we have no idea we literally have no
idea and the only person i can answer
that question is either his cousin
allegedly
or
madison catherine himself right and
speaking of manuscript we played this
video the other day which i think is a
really important video um this is way
more important than any video that
you're gonna see of him doing whatever
the [ __ ] he's doing with his cousin um
because this is the video that matters
we talked about this the other day this
is from april 4th 2022 so this is not
just over a month ago
and this this speech goes into official
record as his belief and his opinion on
the house floor so this video here has
way more uh should have way more weight
you know why we shouldn't [ __ ] vote
these kind of fascists in so watch what
he says in this clip just over a month
ago for
and to reassure all the people out there
his his butt mohawk is not in this video
it is just him speaking speaker
the left has ripped away the pin of
truth from the author of life
they've exchanged natural science for a
party platform and declared war on
biology
your left-wing movement is forcing
children to endure radical expressions
of sexuality and yet you can't even
define what a woman is
you might have been to bill but you'll
never amend biology
science is not burger king you can't
just have it your way
i am the youngest member of the house of
representatives and i never imagined
that one of my sacred duties in this
hallowed chamber would be explaining to
the house speaker the difference between
a man and a woman
take notes madam speaker i'm about to
define what a woman is for you xx
chromosomes
it's so simple
the condescending [ __ ]
fundamental scientific fact [ __ ] [ __ ]
woke liberals in silicon valley to strip
you of your voice and ban you until you
bow at their altar of falsehoods
patriots like charlie kirk and trucker
carlson have been muzzled on twitter for
promoting the dangerous and bigoted
ideology called science
madam speaker you no no it is [ __ ]
bigotry it's anti-science it's all
[ __ ] patriots patriots yeah patriots
[ __ ] patriots right you [ __ ]
also this is what i mean look i'm not
saying that homeschooled
uh
you know comes out with these results
but this kid is giving homeschooling a
very bad name
uh
and uh yeah we should definitely fund
public education just want to say that
again you know these people margie
taylor green greg abbott ron desantis
madison cawthorne all of these [ __ ]
idiots give a very good reason for why
we should continue to fund and and
fund more in public education
um because you know they're trying to
ban things and obviously if you don't
educate yourself then you become one of
these indoctrinating
uh
you know brainwashed fascists that's
what the end result is right well it
never happened if you can't read about
it right here's the other thing too gabe
because i posed the question earlier
this week
are are we the people gonna let
more madison kawhorns be elected because
you said fund education we have to fund
some of these campaigns folks uh shannon
points out this um this video here
because you know a lot of this culture
that he's doing in that video that the
the ask watch video that we watch you
know we we surmise that this culture is
rampant all over and that's what's
happening in that video
but it's the it's the pro i'm gonna
shoot you to take our government back
you know it's not even second amendment
anymore it's we're gonna kill you to to
force our ideas on you we're not only
gonna do that we're gonna make sure to
kill women if so they don't get medical
procedures we'll put them in prison if
we have to we'll jail them uh you know
we'll take away your rights now shannon
points out here this is a a video
of a [ __ ] one of these [ __ ] fascist
uh and i believe it's in yeah it's ohio
and he's a congressional candidate and
it looks like jr
majeski i think his name is majewski
majeski majewski if elected ohio
congressional candidate vows to rip down
our closed signs and shoot you with a
semi-automatic rifle unless you agree to
return america to its quote unquote its
former glory now
um
i want to i want to explain something
about what she's saying because this
isn't like this isn't like he got caught
on camera saying this [ __ ] just like
that pastor right say hi production
right they are put out producing this
video as
a video for his campaign now again at
the very top it says make a great
america dominant again this is this
culture and this is exactly what me and
gabriel are talking about when we're
saying
that madison caught thorn is it just
because you've seen the askwatch video
and that where he's touching his
cousin's touching his crotch video in
the car that does not indicate sexuality
it is about male fascist dominance that
is what it's about it is this male
[ __ ] white male privileged i'm being
oppressed culture and i'm gonna shoot
and kill someone or i'm gonna hump
someone or tea bag someone if they try
to stop me here is here's this watch
this video it's [ __ ] gross but let's
watch it
their agenda is bringing america to its
knees and i'm willing to do whatever
fascism to return this country back to
its former glory
so so at first he says to its knees and
he's alluding to it that's a that's a
homophobic uh trope there yeah um you
know he's he's saying he's saying that
liberals
um
uh soak corks as uh jimmy fallon would
say on a saturn a famous saturday live
skit
but he's alluding that's what he's
alluding to it's a it's a if i'm a white
man and i'm watching this the filter is
that oh oh yeah
it's it's a it's a bunch of gays
right um
giving fellatio that's what he's
suggesting and then which also but i
could also interpret that as like oh you
want to bring someone to your knees it's
like oh you now have to bow down before
me yes there is the sexual kind of
innuendo connotation that's there but i
look at this and i say when you make
that argument of like bow down to your
knees i can make that very same thing
and say when fascists take over and tell
you what to do and you don't do what
they say
and you don't bow down like you got to
get underneath and then i'm not saying
you'll be eliminated or executed but
they will remove you from the situation
he does flip the he does flip the uh the
gun you know
he he does [ __ ] the gun right right at
the end there so let's watch the rest of
this
big gun right well you know it is a lot
a little dick you know in the closet
energy here
and if i got to kick down doors speaking
of that
that's perfect
there's not even a goddamn what's funny
is let's say that he is coming out of
the closet watch it here watch gabe
if i gotta kick down doors well that's
just what patriots do
when i'm elected i won't bother what
what does that mean what that's what
patriots do what is that what does that
mean that they're all coming out of the
closet i don't know maybe break down
doors it sounds like breaking and
entering so you guys are breaking the
law well they they did break into the
capital they did kick down doors to
break into the game maybe that's [ __ ] on
the walls right right well they [ __ ] you
know what's funny about that they had
actually [ __ ] in their hands yeah yeah
like they they were like
i wonder if they had like disinfectant
wipes or something maybe they had hand
sanitizer about it i think you know they
all brought their little sandwiches and
their snacks and they were eating it
right with it you think they were eating
poop sandwiches eating sandwich yeah you
know
it happens [ __ ] eaters okay let's let's
let's listen to this [ __ ] eater little
establishment pawns or power hungry
radicals
i will hold my own and what's funny
about that power hungary radicals like
it's literally radical like literally
the extremist gqp is trying to do
everything they can to get
knuckleheads like this to come out and
vote for him like the most extreme
[ __ ] policies they want to jail women
for having a medical procedure charging
with a felony homicide felony homicide
for having a
taking plan b if they need it
oh my god this is [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
let's listen my own and demand that once
again america stands independent and
strong like the country that i fought
for
patriots the cowardice ends with us it's
time to restore american dominance
what's funny go back sorry go back to
where he knocks the sign off yeah
correct
all right all right
yeah play it
patriots cowardice is with us
so obviously this is this is like an
abandoned warehouse is this an abandoned
warehouse is it just like knocking down
the sign makes this an open business or
yeah he's like uh knocked it down
we should totally should do a parody of
this video i know we should totally do
somebody minus margie says uh gabe
should do a video threatening them with
a soda spray
[Laughter]
oh thank you audience thank you
listeners for probably joining in
finally joining in my sodastream with uh
uh joining in on giving gabe [ __ ] about
his sodastream thank you audience thank
you listeners for following my lead
there uh this is perfect um what what a
what a way to to get into friday here so
yeah maybe we'll do a parody of this at
this bonun because i probably could do
this i could do this guys oh yeah i mean
oh i definitely could yeah
you got you got
you got the woods around you and stuff
or you got a place where you can go i
mean we'll just take his video and i'll
i'll dub over him oh okay yeah
i was also thinking that maybe you could
just film in your house like like weekly
kick open the door maybe trip down the
stairs a little bit you know no i think
we keep the same video yeah we can keep
the same video over yeah we just dub
over it maybe all right use part of his
voice part of mine i'll try to imagine
we'll do something like that maybe and
then you know what you know what we'll
do
and instead of airing it on twitter and
that stuff maybe we'll we'll put this on
the youtube uh saturday
satire and parody yeah the series
charity uh playlist i'm combining words
there it's friday man it's been a long
week um i'm getting to the end here so
now we'll put it on that playlist mate
maybe that's what we'll do we'll make a
plan for next week to try to get this
out there and then uh and then once it
goes
this weekend uh yeah exactly i'm dubbing
over this video um so
this is not if you want more madison
cothorns in this country now this guy's
running for state office i i believe
maybe he's running for
uh a state or a united states
congressional uh seat i don't know it's
in ohio she said ohio congressional
candidate so it could be state office or
uh federal office but if you want more
madison cawthornes here you go here's
the guy
and i'm sorry he's a oh my god hold on
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait this
guy is a mega rapper
who painted his lawn for trump
won
he won
he also went to dc
for the wait wait sixth insurrection oh
this is perfect so uh us clowning this
guy is absolutely up our alley let's
let's make this guy a a tony michael's
podcast let's let's figure out some
content to make around this [ __ ]
chucklehead he won the primary so he is
so he is on the ballot and i think
that's what she won the gop nomination
to ohio's ninth congressional seat
yesterday yes uh and i think that's what
why shannon posted this yeah and i
retweeted because i was like this guy's
a [ __ ] nut job do you want to see his
lawn
yeah sure give me a link to his lawn
we'll do that and then and then we'll
move to the next we'll move to our
dishonorable mention after we look at
this guy's lawn
mark esper
um for those folks out there who don't
know mark esper held all kinds of
information that the american people
should have known
to make a choice in an election and he
chose to hold it for profit
yep i'm sick and tired of these [ __ ]
well
it's not surprising that they would do
this
so but let's let's let's do this let's
look at this oh
hang on here let's look at this guy's
lawn here first
he painted
his
lawn so it's hard to see there it says
trump 2020 dash dash dash
so in other words he wants him to be a
dictator yep
and and then it says make america great
make america great i don't know over
yeah it's a big drum flag i think oh so
he's he's he's uh
yeah he took it all the way to the
corner yeah
[Music]
that's really cool you can see that not
from a from a helicopter or an airplane
probably because it's so badly done i'm
sure he was like yeah i want google map
or like google earth to find me what a
dumb [ __ ] um so back to our dishonorable
mention gabe
explain to our audience what pisses you
off most about this because it pisses me
off but what do you mark esper is
another one of these profiteering
[ __ ] who held onto information
and waited to release it in a book and
make money on it right
the the publishers are just as bad in
the scenario i get that they have to
make money and obviously they're gonna
you know the the juicy gossip cells and
whatnot but when you're someone who
holds onto information maggie haberman
reveals in her book that trump was
eating documents and trying to flush him
down the toilet you know bill barr's
telling his regrets of being in the
presidency bolton is revealing secrets
uh you've got uh uh who else um bill
barr john bolton i mean the [ __ ] list
goes on and on you've got stephanie
grisham who says oh
i'm having a moment of
of uh
of 2020 hindsight and i've seen i i'm
having this this moment where
i i saw what happened and i was in the
presidency and i was the press secretary
for a short period of time and instead
of saying something during the time she
waited to then
release a book after the fact mark esper
this is two years after the fact we're
finding out that trump
wanted to bomb
the cartel and the drug labs that were
in mexico and then from i mean mind you
from a landlocked missile position and
then blame it
on someone else and be like
america didn't do it that's how we got
our title today exactly and these people
you know bob woodward is another one
right he's he knew back in february that
trump said it was deadlier than the
virus despite the fact that the things
that trump were saying in public was
it's not so bad it's not as bad as the
flu uh it'll go away in two weeks by
easter it'll be all cured right
these are the people that held on to
this [ __ ] information so that they
could write a book about it and profit
these people are just as bad as the
people that they report on
they do not get a free hall pass because
they're being a hero or a patriot for
now coming forward
they are just as disgusting and vile and
hypocritical as the people that they
write about
and these journalists
should be using their power and these
people from the administration should be
using their power to come forward and
speak out about what's being done not
hold on to it
for the next or for rather hold on to it
for the highest bidder
so you were talking about how he wanted
to bomb mexico and donald trump jr maybe
we'll if you can find that tweet for me
i'll i'll pull that [ __ ] boneheaded
tweet up um but uh don junior said yeah
we should bomb mexico what are you crazy
of course that's a good idea basically
is what he said um but here's an
interview
with esper himself by nora o'donnell
because the other thing that was said
about mexico that esper was taken aback
is when stephen miller you guys know the
ghoul the the gerbils ghoul that is the
nazi stephen miller and was a um a
campaign aide and he was in the white
house as an advisor yeah actually
yeah he's the architect he's the
architect
of the border right uh yeah caging
children
in separating families he wanted to send
a half a million troops apparently to
the border our military he wanted to
send to the border which is not exactly
how it works um but let's listen to the
interview here who suggested that we
send a quarter million quarter million
u.s troops wrong to the border stephen
miller we're in a meeting waiting for
the president to come out we're standing
around the resolute desk
and uh he's behind me and this voice
just starts talking about the caravans
are coming and
and we need to get troops to the border
and we need a quarter million troops and
i think he's joking and then i turn
around and i look at him and he's in
these deadpan eyes it's clearly he is
not joking
and so i i say something like well look
dhs can handle whatever caravans are
coming up
so mark esper you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ] didn't you get on the
horn and let the american people know
that that's what these dumb [ __ ] wanted
to do
you stupid piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] this is the most
un-american thing i've ever heard of in
my really it is [ __ ] gross that this
guy is he was the secretary of defense
for defending our [ __ ] border
and here he is in a [ __ ] official
meeting with the goddamn president his
advisors and one of his advisors
has the stupid [ __ ] idea to send a
quarter million troops to the border he
thinks he's joking he realizes that he's
not he knows these people are trying to
remain in [ __ ] power he probably
knows they're trying to commit a [ __ ]
coup
why in the actual [ __ ] didn't mark esper
do this goddamn interview in 2020. you
spineless piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you were
not a patriot you were unamerican and
frankly you deserve to be cast out into
the history books as
as un-american and you tried to topple
our democracy because you withheld
information for money in your own mother
[ __ ] pockets that piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the people the people from this group is
is profit over people right that is
exactly what they did and the whole
[ __ ] caravan thing i just want to
point out there is no [ __ ] caravan
that is coming from mexico into the u.s
the only caravan is [ __ ] ted cruz
driving across the border to cancun okay
a dodge [ __ ] caravan that's the only
caravan there is not a group of people
that we have to worry about right these
people are trying to seek refuge and as
good republican christians we should
allow them to come in and give them
shelter right because you're easily
going to hire them for the services that
and jobs that you don't want to do but
then you want to complain you want to
complain that these people who are
trying to live or work for the american
dream
are not worthy
the same people who are trying to force
birth on women
the
it is it is insulting and disgusting and
someone who is
who is mexican a mexican-american so i
bare i i share both sides of the border
here
and to hear
whether it's i want to bomb the cartel
in mexico and blame it on another
country as if the us didn't do it and to
have someone like this who is
architecting this this vile disgusting
plan of of separating parents from their
fam from their children in mexico and
putting them in cages and then not only
that but then allowing mark esper
to then say yeah you know what yeah
we'll we'll uh we'll have you want to
write a book
like the publishers again these people
are just as bad as the ones that they
report on or that they want to like be
the whistleblower about
but the publishers in the situation
they're just as bad as them [ __ ] yeah
they're probably all in the same group
as [ __ ] let's listen to the rest of
this [ __ ] they've done so in the
past and he said and he said he repeats
no we need a quarter million troops and
i just turned squarely around to him
face him and say i don't have a quarter
million troops to send on some
ridiculous mission to the border and i
told this story to
general milley and my chief of staff you
didn't tell the american people you
[ __ ]
i said let's be safe let's just check
and make sure
let's just keep moving
somewhere in the building and milly
comes back days later
and the door opens up and he's waving
a document in his enhance and he says
something like secretary you're not
going to believe this
and that's when he explains to me that
yes they were working that we had
developed a plan initial concept of how
this might happen and i was just
flabbergasted that not only was the idea
proposed but that people people in my
department were working on it
so why why this [ __ ] didn't actually
alert of the american people to this is
is beyond me but also he just revealed
that someone in his own department was
doing something behind his back right
spent time and resources and money to
come up with a [ __ ] stack of papers
that had a plan and then say hey hey
it's a real planet's real plan but
instead of firing them instead of
removing them instead of calling them
out and casting them out like a leper
right he says ah we'll keep him here
we'll keep him right and speaking of
cast out like a leper we need to get rid
of this [ __ ] coke kid this is
ridiculous this is [ __ ] absolutely
ridiculous i don't know why we have to
[ __ ] listen to this chucklehead yap
and yap and yap day after day after day
this is [ __ ] ridiculous that we have
to listen to this
absolute bonehead booger sugar junior
here and this is all distraction here
gabe he says i'm still trying to figure
out
the recent media outrage media outrage
what do you talk it's human outrage you
dumb [ __ ] about my father possibly
wanting to target mexican cartel
manufacturing facilities in mexico no
you wanted to commit war acts
against a [ __ ] ally you dumb
[ __ ] the translation here is i'm
still trying to figure out why people
are outraged at the fact that my dad
wanted to bomb mexico right bomb mexico
and kill mexicans what a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] he said is that supposed to be a
bad thing listen to me folks when i tell
you this they're gonna get on stage at
the next couple the next couple trump
rallies and they're gonna say this type
of [ __ ] they're gonna say
hey it's a good idea that we should we
should allow donald trump to be
president so he can bomb mexico they're
gonna say it folks they're gonna say it
[ __ ] your tweet
meanwhile
don jr while he's writing this
is also oh no [ __ ] that thanks for the
tweet
uh meanwhile
don jr in this situation
is uh also afraid he's like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] if they uh if they bomb mexico then
where's my supply gonna come from right
here's gabe's uh here's gabe dude i i
rewrote this thing
probably nine to ten times there was a
lot of different things i was gonna say
why'd you land on this word
it was the easiest way uh pen
what is it what does it mean what does
it mean
it's uh it means like idiot like uh
something it's like a it's like a
nicer way to say the son of a [ __ ]
um but uh yeah i was i i wrote out
multiple lines of text that basically
was like i hate this [ __ ]
uh that is donald trump and his son
donald trump jr and i went through when
i went through and i went through and i
just was like you know what i'm just
going to say spanish well that's good
there you go that's perfect perfect
thank you for the tweet okay let's move
on um to
our alpha kevin mccarthy
why did we put the alpha cup as kevin
mccarthy we're running out of time here
so
tapes tapes tapes tapes tape tapes you
know i tweeted i tweeted okay and you
pointed it out i think yesterday or the
day before i tweeted uh we got the we
got the uh we got the memo our emails we
got the tapes where's the vids and then
we got the askwatch video so yeah we had
that so um
so thanks kevin mccarthy for making
another appearance here on bone of the
week as the alpha cuck this week um but
i want to go to our winner our winner is
j j chief justice samuel alito
um of course we know in his decision
tell us gabe tell us have you read uh
parts of his decision tell us what you
think tell us what you think about
samuel leto and why he won here and then
we'll we'll give him right his uh his
justification
for
um
his decision right his draft decision
was
uh is said it's opening the door to roll
back things for
hundreds of years right um he's there
are several cases that would you know
people would make
that could say oh you know what well
because this right was taken away we
also want to take this right which could
be interracial marriage we could be
same-sex marriage you know there's a
brown versus education people are
talking about which is you know like
whether
whether or not people should be you know
uh
in terms of in terms of um race and
education like there are there are many
things that this could potentially open
the door for if you were to take one
right away
then it's a slippery slope to go well
they're also kind of in this category
and they're tangentially related so we
could also
do that right you'll find all these
southern states below that you know the
bible belt that will be fighting for
these things to go back to how america
really was make america great you know
bring it back to the confederacy right
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] the cheeto dust
confederacy right exactly
these are the the the type of reasoning
that they put in besides the fact that
he just outright lied right just like
the video that we watched from midas
touch it was every single one of these
supreme court justices who said it was
precedent it was established as law it
was uh it was it was it was not going to
be overturned right they had said it was
challenged and yeah because because we
see plant we see roe v wade and then you
see in the 1990s i believe it's 1992
exactly that we see planned parenthood
versus casey which rolled it back but it
all but not only did it roll it back but
it it solidified that the woman had to
write to her own body and the choices
that she made the other reason why this
[ __ ] bonehead ended up here he
actually wrote this in his decision here
in the draft that is uh the initial
draft domestic supply of infants so it's
like
literally human beings are inventory is
how he reversed him that [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] so let's let's do let's give
let's give uh federal society
alito because he's not i don't think
he's a supreme court justice at this
point he's not a chief either now [ __ ]
him um so let's let's give him his due
here for bonehead of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] justice alito [ __ ] him hard over
and over [ __ ] him
now thank you for joining us for
bonehead of the week again go to at
tonymichaelspod
and follow us on twitter for next week's
bonehead of the week you'll find it
thursday and then every friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
we go through your vote on bone of the
week you can also subscribe to our
youtube channel and find the poll there
from now on on our youtube channel do
not forget to go there and again this
this bonus of the week airs every single
friday in the second hour of our show
and our show the tony michaels podcast
airs every single weekday gabe yeah you
know that monday through friday
yeah last week we started it we were
like you know what we're going to go
seven days a week yeah that's right
and that's the other good point that i
want to make about bonehead is on
sundays now we will cut the bone end of
the week out of the show we will air it
on the youtube channel so that's why
it's important to go there
we will also download it on all your
favorite directories apple spotify
google you can find it there boom to
download it so not only will you have
this great video version but you will
now every single week on sunday
have the
bonehead of the week audio version take
it go for a run get that cathartic
that's right
you know that's right
uh gabe what a great bonus we thank you
everyone for voting this week and we'll
today quite a week
today was
today was quite a quite a month a year
decade jesus christ thank you for
joining us bone end of the week stick
around we'll be right back for a couple
announcements on the show thanks for
joining us bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]